all right xi jinping
you asked for it
no more mr nice biden
no more mr friendly chocolate chocolate
chip ice cream guy no way
you think that you can just
steal american intellectual property and
take american
manufacturing and and take over
semi-sovereign states
and
run concentration camps to genocide your
own people
and start a global pandemic and shut
down the whole world for a couple years
without consequences
i don't think so buddy jen
tell them what we're going to do
the biden administration will not send
any diplomatic or official
representation to the beijing 2022
winter olympics and paralympic games
given the pierre scenes ongoing genocide
and crimes against
humanity in xinjiang and other human
rights abuses the athletes on team usa
have our full support we will be behind
them 100 percent as we cheer them on
from home we will not be contributing to
the fanfare of the games us diplomatic
or official representation would treat
these games as business as usual in the
face of the prc's egregious human rights
abuses and atrocities in xinjiang and we
simply can't do that as the president
has told president xi standing up for
human rights is in the dna
of americans we have a fundamental
commitment to promoting human rights and
we feel strongly in our position and we
will continue to take actions to advance
human rights in china and beyond
we're going to continue to take big
actions like
a diplomatic boycott of the olympics
you know like we're still going to send
all the players and stuff and we're
still going to totally participate in
the olympics
but we're not going to send any
government employees which means that
you
you don't get a photograph with pete
buddha judge take that jinping i'm
michael knowles that's the michael
knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from farside sc who
says
although i found the jersey shore
reference on yesterday's show or today
so this was today's show but yesterday
because i'm talking to you now it's the
future
although i found the jersey shore
reference to be humorous
uh whoever knew the reference on your
staff should be fired for having watched
the show
oh that staff member should be fired is
that so well then i guess there's not
going to be much of a show anymore
moving into there won't be much of a
michael knowles show that's for sure
i sound like i'm kamala harris you know
and you know and that little staff
member was me that was me who watched
the show and it's a great show it's the
greatest reality tv show ever when you
watch things
like the jersey shore
or the i don't know or the daily wire
things that maybe you don't want the
authorities to know about so they send
you off to the re-education camps you
should check out expressvpn it is so
easy to hack somebody did you know that
and every time you log on to the
internet at a at a cafe or at the
airport or in a hotel i'm in a hotel
right now
every time you log in you are exposing a
lot of your data which is why i never do
it without expressvpn on my phone and on
my computer hacking someone is so easy a
12 year old can do it and
hackers can make a thousand bucks per
person for the the data that they sell
on the dark web don't do it use
expressvpn creates a secure encrypted
tunnel between your device and the
internet it's super easy to use it's
just one button and then you're done you
don't have to think about it again works
on all these devices phones laptops
tablets right now do what i do protect
your data and your identity online go to
expressvpn.com
michael mich ael that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
michael m-i-c-h-a-e-l head on over there
you will get an extra three months for
free at expressvpn expressvpn.com
michael especially during the christmas
season when you're buying a lot of stuff
online protect your data
the diplomatic boycott of the chinese
olympics
is
a completely meaningless gesture
it does not scare china in the least it
does not have any
consequences for china if the united
states kept the players away from the
olympic games that might have some
effect it would certainly tarnish the
credibility of the olympics it would
certainly
uh take down the ratings the ratings
would not be as strong
but
but withholding some diplomats and some
cabinet officials or
booty judge it's not
not going to do anything it's it's
it almost would have been better if the
united states had done nothing at all
but to go out and say as gensake did
there is a genocide going on in china
the leader of china is slaughtering
whole races of people in concentration
camps
and then
to
move forward with this weak meaningless
action it's worse than doing nothing at
all and it sends the message that the
united states is not serious
does does anyone really believe that if
really when
china goes into taiwan china goes into
the united states interests in the south
china sea that the u.s is going to go
send in the marines does anyone believe
that does anyone think
after pulling out 20 years of war in
afghanistan after all the wars in the
middle east does anyone really think
that the american people want to go to
war
in asia
to save taiwan or some other island no
no no one really believes that xi
jinping doesn't think that
this is the weakest possible response
from an administration that is
extraordinarily weak
now sometimes the weakness of the biden
administration actually benefits
conservatives and the american people
more broadly we're seeing this right now
when it comes to joe biden's vaccine
mandate
so
right now
joe biden is
it has issued multiple vaccine mandates
it gets a little bit confusing because
there's the government employee vaccine
mandate this is the government
contractor vaccine mandate there's the
osha vaccine mandate which uses the
occupational safety and health
administration to force some employers
and players with 100 or more employees
to force their employees to get the
fouchyache that's the one that the daily
wire is fighting and we're winning on
but joe
joe manchin rather a democratic senator
ostensibly part of joe's party
is
saying no he doesn't want to go along
with this
and
he's actually saying now
that he
will side with the republicans
to work on a bill that will undermine
his own presidents
and his party leaders vaccine mandate he
says quote i do not support
any government vaccine mandate on
private businesses that's why i have
co-sponsored and will strongly support a
bill to overturn the federal government
vaccine mandate for private businesses
the lesson here
is simple stand firm
stand firm a little courage goes a long
way
when joe biden issued his vaccine
mandate he thought he could get away
with it because the democrats can
control the entire government they have
both houses of congress and they have
the white house
and the courts aren't particularly
favorable favorable to republicans
either even though
there are plenty of republican judges
there
he thought joe biden thought i've got
the administrative state i've got the
media i've got hollywood i've got
woke corporate america i've got the
schools i've got everything and so i can
do this and no one's going to fight back
and then a handful of people fought back
and i don't want to brag too much here
as someone from the daily wire but the
daily wire led that charge
among the private employers and we sued
the biden administration in the sixth
circuit court of appeals
other people sued in the fifth circuit
court of appeals and we're winning and
we're very clearly winning
and when you show a little bit of
courage that's going to show other
people that they can show a little bit
of courage and that's what's going on
right here and joe manchin is standing
up to the leader of his own party
and now it looks like we're going to win
and there's very little that the
democrats
can do about that
shows there's not unity even within the
democratic party here now
at the local level it doesn't matter
places that are completely blue so blue
they're actually red not red like
republicans red like the commies
they're going to push for even more
vaccine mandates you're seeing this in
new york right now bill de blasio
has announced just yesterday that he is
going to force all
private sector employees in new york
city
to take the fouchy algae
we in new york city have decided to
use a preemptive strike to really do
something bold to stop the further
growth of covid and the dangers it's
causing to all of us so
as of today we're going to announce a
first in the nation measure our health
commissioner will announce a vaccine
mandate for private sector employers
across the board
all private sector employers in new york
city will be covered by this vaccine
mandate as of december 27th we're going
to have some other measures as well to
really focus on maximizing vaccination
quickly so we can get ahead of omicron
and all the other challenges we're
facing right now with covet
de blasio's going to launch a
pre-emptive strike 21 months after two
weeks to slow the spread it's going to
be very preemptive
because of the omicron
and you know the omicron that hasn't
killed anybody yet in the omicron that
doesn't seem
particularly dangerous compared to the
other variants
yes he's going to launch this vaccine
mandate a lot of conservatives are
saying bill de blasio doesn't have the
right to do this this is a violation of
fundamental rights i don't think that's
true and i don't think it's a winning
line of argument i think bill de blasio
has the right to do this i think
especially local governments they have
the right to enforce a whole lot of laws
that i don't like including
vaccine mandates they have the political
right we have some individual rights
but we also have political rights as a
community and one of those rights that
has been asserted in the united states
going back 115 years at least
is the right to
public health and specifically the right
to vaccines and inoculations and
mandating that people do that so i'm not
i'm not denying that bill de blasio has
that political right i think it's a
terrible decision i think as a
prudential matter it's it's awful i
would oppose it vigorously but the only
question that matters is not whether
bill de blasio has some abstract
political right it's does he have the
political power to enforce this
the good news for new yorkers and don't
don't free i was born and raised in new
york i have a great deal of love for my
fellow new yorkers who are unfortunately
suffering under under bill de blasio the
good news is he's a lame duck
he's on his way out there's a new mayor
that's coming in
and so he doesn't have a ton of
political power if i were giving
prudential advice to employers in new
york right now and maybe i am giving
credential advice to them i would say
just shrug your shoulders maybe drag
your feet a little bit maybe slow walk
this thing de blasio's a lame duck we
need to turn all these guys into lame
ducks this is a good issue this issue of
forced vaccinations specifically in
schools for specifically these are
winning issues that can bring together a
whole coalition of people not just the
hard right far conservative
traditionalists not even just the
libertarians but even disaffected
liberals
too got to get much more prudent wide as
a serpent innocent as a dove all that
prattling around about abstract rights
isn't going to save you a single freedom
or way of life in new york or elsewhere
you've got to fight back on the level of
political
power
you know
when it comes to political power i like
to hear lots of different points of view
i like to listen to lots of different
podcasts and audiobooks and when i do
i love to use raycons if you're like me
you put off getting your christmas
presents until the last minute and then
you think oh what am i going to get my
wife and then i actually have done this
you google
gifts to get your wife or you go gifts
to get your dad or gifts together and
you know okay how about a gift that
everyone will love i'm talking about
recons which i actually did give to my
dad a couple of christmases ago and then
i had one for myself i was so excited i
got my raycons they were great they
sound great they're super sleek looking
come in lots of cool different colors
they don't have those little stems
sticking out that make you look like a
bug really high quality earbuds and they
start at a much lower price point than
some of the competitors but i don't have
them anymore because my wife
took them from me so maybe this year for
christmas maybe i'll get myself a few
more pairs
the price is so low and reasonable you
could do that you can get a pair and a
spare this christmas season knock out
that gift list avoid the last minute
shipping scramble
especially with all the supply chain
nonsense head on over and get 15
site-wide with code holiday
d a h-o-l-i-d-a-y
at buy raycon dot com slash knowles
canada l e s that website buyreacon.com
knowles head over there right now use
code holiday to get 15
off your friends your family your loved
ones and you will thank me
if you stand up against the liberal
ruling class you are going to be
vilified
that is guaranteed and you are going to
be called a racist why i don't know you
will and a sexist huh where does that
come from i don't know that's just what
they're going to call you they're going
to go so far as to call you a murderer
they're already doing that they're
saying if you don't do exactly what we
say even if our if our guidelines
contradict themselves one day to the
next if you don't do exactly what we say
you are a murderer you're responsible
for the epidemic you're responsible for
people dying this is what the cackling
hens on the view said just yesterday
about the new
spooky
oh micron variant
they feel that their greater good is
more important than your greater good
well you know it was interesting to me
that the argument was being made if
you're vaccinated why do you care about
me being vaccinated you're protected and
that's why we are at the um
omarion omicron variant right that's why
we are where we are because it's
mutating it's becoming this crazy
superbug inside of the people that
aren't vaccinated and now it's affecting
us i don't know why they were not
understanding that we've got like 80
million people
vaccinated
they understand
they don't want to yeah here we all we
all
so first of all the cdc has already told
us that the vaccine does not totally
prevent you from contracting the virus
or transmitting the virus they told us
this at the end of july this is why the
vaccinated are still required to wear
masks even in lots of different settings
even after they've received the vaccine
this is why people are receiving all of
these boosters and now we're being told
in israel they're contemplating
requiring a fourth shot to be fully
vaccinated and there seems to be no end
in sight so spare me the sanctimony
there but furthermore let's just take
them at their word the unvaccinated are
causing or they're leading the the cause
of the new variants
and they're petria dishes and they're
creating all these new variants of covid
what we are told right now by the
scientists by all the geniuses
is that the new
omicron
is less
dangerous than the delta variant for
instance or the original variant or some
of the other flavors
as well
when viruses mutate
they generally speaking become
less dangerous
and these less dangerous strains can
become
the predominant strains
isn't that a good thing don't we want it
if you've got a relatively dangerous
variant and then it mutates and becomes
relatively less dangerous
and then the relatively less dangerous
one becomes the predominant strain
isn't that
better than letting the more dangerous
one be the predominant strain am i
am i stupid am i thick am i not reading
things correctly here's this from the
new york times i'm definitely going to
be stupid if i keep reading the new york
times the new york times headline
omicron is moving fast
but perhaps less severe
early reports
suggest
researchers in south africa where the
variant is spreading quickly say it may
cause less serious covid cases than
other forms of the virus but it's
unclear whether that will hold true
maybe that'll change over time that's
right as of now as of recording i don't
think anyone has died from omicron so
why is everybody freaking out
we should be happy that the virus is
becoming less and less severe as viruses
do that's just that's just what happens
that's why we're not living through the
spanish flu 1918 every single year
we're living through endemic sort of
seasonal flus that are not particularly
severe
at least we were before covet then last
year the flu basically just disappeared
remember that that was kind of strange
too
speaking of people getting vilified by
the media
i've got to
i've got to take the side of the victim
i've got to take the side of the man
who's down and out i'm going to take the
widow's corner i am going to
stand up for poor fredo cuomo poor fredo
cuomo
has done a lot of bad things i don't
particularly like him i'm thrilled that
the house of cuomo is done politically
speaking
but i think
i think that
they're doing him a little dirty okay he
lost a cnn show we've now found out that
fredo has lost his serious xm show this
is his explanation for it
the way my time ended at cnn was hard
while i have a thick skin i also have a
family for whom the past week has been
extraordinarily difficult so right now i
have to take a step backward and focus
on what comes next that means i will no
longer be doing my serious xm radio show
i'm extremely grateful for the support
i've received from siriusxm throughout
my time there i also want to express my
sincere appreciation for my loyal
listeners i will miss our conversations
a great deal but i look forward to being
back in touch with you all in the future
so
this can be one of two things one i
don't think this is particularly
voluntary i don't think he gave up his
only other source of employment just
because i'm going to take a step back i
suspect he's done people are going after
him so why either it's because there's
another shoe to drop either it's because
they've got a bunch of scandals up their
sleeve that they're going to drop on him
and they're either threatening to
release it if they don't play nice if he
doesn't play nice or it is already going
to come out and and cuomo's trying to
get ahead of the story and back out so
that's one option or
there's no more serious scandal coming
out and fredo cuomo is just no longer
politically useful to the left to cnn
and to sirius his dad mario cuomo is
dead his brother politically is dead and
so why do we have chris cuomo around
anymore he's not
he's not particularly valuable
politically so
he's out
he's canceled he's done which is why i
think this is going to sound like a
little bit of an out there proposal but
just hear me out
i think
the daily wire should hire him you know
that's what we do we hire
we hire people who get canceled
all right we we did it with gina carano
now we got this great movie with gina
carano we did it with
sports journalists we've done it with
political journalists we we stand up for
people who get cancer and i think
that we need to bring the chris cuomo
show over to the daily wire it would be
so funny obviously we would need a lot
of editorial control we would need chris
cuomo to just basically say things that
we agree with but i think it would be
hilarious i would do it for the laws
chris if you're watching this show i
assume you are
think about it
ben if you're watching this show i know
you're not think about it too please
chris cuomo
is trying to manage his cancellation
right now and
i think everyone involved is trying to
do it relatively as nicely as a
cancellation can go
but there are already fault lines there
are already tensions you can see
chris cuomo for instance just making a
statement
that
jeff zucker the head of cnn
knew exactly what he was doing the whole
time
so chris cuomo gets fired not for lying
to his audience not for lying about
kovid not for that ridiculous special
where he pretended to quarantine
remember for a period of time wouldn't
see his family and then they filmed him
coming out of quarantine and oh wow i
get to see my family again except we
found out that was a lie he was hanging
out with his family the whole time he
went on bike rides in the hamptons and
actually the way we know about that is
because he got into a fight with a guy
in the hamptons while on a bicycle so
not for lying not for his dishonesty no
he's gonna get fired for helping his
brother what that doesn't seem
fair so then people raised some
questions about this and now you're
hearing talk of potential sexual
harassment allegations which
generally appear when people are
politically weak and on the verge of
being canceled you just you sprinkle a
few of those on top it's like sprinkles
on an ice cream sundae right he helped
his brother he's no longer politically
useful that's the ice cream and the
chocolate fudge and the and the
frosting on top and the whipped cream
but then you put some sexual assault
allegations that's the little sprinkles
on top of the sundae
so
a spokesman for cuomo just said in a
text message quote
mr cuomo has the highest level of
admiration and respect for mr zucker
they were widely known to be extremely
close and in regular contact including
about the details of mr cuomo's support
for his brother there were no secrets
about this as the other individuals as
other individuals besides mr cuomo can
attest
yeah ah there it is there is cuomo
twisting that knife with a big smile on
his face just a spokesman spokesman just
saying look no no these men are really
close chris has such respect for mr
zucker oh yeah chris and mr zucker are
super tight oh yeah they talk about
everything and mr zucker knows about
everything and other friends of zuckers
and cuomo's know that zucker knows about
everything so don't try it buddy don't
try this don't pretend
that chris cuomo was out here on his own
helping his brother and no one knew
about it that's obviously i said this on
the show you know i hate to tell you i
told you so i said everyone at cnn knew
about this there's no new information
in terms of what cnn knew about their
host
nothing has changed in the past week or
two
all that has changed is the political
calculation and now they're going to
pretend oh gosh we're rooting out
corruption bs
bs now these sexual assault allegations
i don't know maybe they're sexual
harassment or whatever they're vaguely
insinuating they seem trumped up to me
they seem fake maybe they're true but
what it seems to me is cnn got caught
they got caught in some really corrupt
practices they're trying to throw fredo
under the bus they're trying to take him
out on that lake in that little fishing
boat and fredo
fredo is in a standoff right now okay
and they're not but i hope
i have to tell you
this is like the iran-iraq war i hope
they both lose
you know
when you want to
win not lose but win
i would really strongly urge you to go
check out hunter douglas so i did not
know this
before getting married and getting a
house i did not know how important
window treatments are
not just for how your house looks but
how you feel in your house
one of the most important things about
your apartment or about your house is
going to be light we love light we want
to go toward the light you know we want
the light to fill up our rooms and you
want it to be
managed in a really elegant beautiful
way hunter douglas has incredible shades
that will diffuse harsh sunlight to cast
a beautiful glow across the room you can
enjoy the view outside of the window
while protecting your privacy inside
they've got great insulation
it's really wonderful keeps you warm in
the winter cooler in the summer lowers
utility bills they've got that
goldilocks moment when you walk into the
room this has happened to me and you
just think ah the light is perfect
live beautifully with hunter douglas you
can beauty is very important we
understand that we are aesthetes we
recognize that beauty shapes the way we
view the world how we feel enjoy greater
convenience enhanced style and increased
comfort in your home throughout the day
with
hunter douglas also right now you've got
to subscribe to the morning wire if you
are not tuning into the morning wire
you're not getting your news in the
morning in that quick 15 minute no not a
ton of commentary not a ton of analysis
just here are the facts you know the
left is really good at this that's why
they have the new york times and they
have npr and what they do is they
pretend to give you the facts and they
speak in a really quiet voice
you know and they say hi welcome to the
new york times i'm michael
bah-bah-bah-bah and joe biden is good
and trump is bad you know and they're
giving you a lot of leftist opinion but
in a in a way that seems like they're
just giving you the facts so we think
that's bs we're going to do our own
morning show we're going to do it really
just the facts really quick 15 minutes
uh so go check out morning wire also you
got to get matt walsh's new book not
because he's the number one [ __ ]
best-selling children's author in
america
he's also the number one best-selling
lgbtq author in america matt walsh gotta
love him head on over to
johnnythewalrus.com j-o-h-n-n-y the the
walrus dot
com we'll be right back with a lot more
welcome back to the show some really
good news coming out of washington that
is a sentence i almost never say
but there is really good news and we
have a handful of republican senators to
thank for this notably ted cruz great
fan
friend of the show rather
uh hawley josh hawley
sponsored this amendment
the great news is that
we might not yet as a nation start
drafting women and sending them into the
line of fire
you'll remember that during the
vote over the national defense
authorization act there was a provision
that the libs put in there to draft
women
and some squish republicans went along
with this and it's disgusting to me a
vote for
drafting women is basically
disqualifying
if you are a conservative
but
a lot of people went along and a lot of
other conservatives didn't raise a
ruckus there were a handful of us who
said this is disgusting this is shameful
anyone who votes for this
sh does not deserve to walk into the
capitol
does not deserve their seat in the house
or in the senate and so
some of the good guys in the senate
pulled it out
josh hawley last month
introduced an amendment to the ndaa that
would strip out that language about
drafting women
the amendment was co-sponsored by ted
cruz tom cotton roger marshall roger
wicker cindy hyde-smith steve daines
james lankford john boozman mike lee and
marco rubio and i i say all of their
names because they deserve credit here
they deserve credit for taking that out
if we as a nation
start drafting women and sending them to
go die in the middle east or whatever
we're going to send them to do
we are not a nation worth defending
okay what what do we stand for
the whole reason that people go out
there and fight to defend this country
is to protect the women and the children
and our way of life but you're telling
me you libs and you squishes that go
along with it that
you want to
upend that way of life upend those
standards send the very thing that we're
protecting the very people we're
protecting the very
institutions we're protecting send them
overseas through throw them under the
bus or get rid of them entirely it's
ridiculous
and what some of the squishes would say
or the liberals would say is well you
know look men and women are there men
women are just the same as men and they
should have all the same
responsibilities and opportunities and
as men do including getting drafted and
dying overseas uh no they're not the
same as men that's the point guys
remember we're the conservatives you
remember that we're the ones who say
men and women are different stuff like
that and there's a biological reality
and there's things like chivalry and we
should hold the door for women you know
and we should
because we're different and all that
but yeah but women want equal rights so
that yeah right but
the libs just because the libs and the
feminists say that men and women are
exactly the same doesn't mean that we
should go along with that it's not
owning the libs to accept all of their
fundamental premises
that's called that's called owning
yourself
okay
don't don't do that so great job to all
these guys clearly showing some moral
clarity and speaking of moral clarity
i've got to address a topic
that oh gosh this got me in a lot of
trouble
over the weekend
i was on twitter you know just wasting
time on twitter and
we were debating abortion
and all these libs were very upset that
there's a chance that the supreme court
will overturn roe versus wade and then
hopefully we conservatives can go
further and ban abortion everywhere make
it illegal and prosecute abortionists
and rights this is
basic stuff
and the libs lost their minds and said
that this is terrible and you know
abortion's a wonderful thing and i
pointed out abortion is the worst thing
america's ever done and the libs thought
they had a trump card they said
how dare you say that michael how dare
you say that abortion is worse than
slavery
of course abortion is worse than slavery
abortion is much much much worse than
slavery
it's not even close
by any by just about any metric that i
can think of
other than the most
inhuman materialist standard that takes
no account of moral or ethical or
metaphysical reality abortion is much
much much worse than slavery
just on
the standard of liberalism just on the
standard of you know we have natural
rights to life liberty and the pursuit
of happiness
if you're talking about abortion
and slavery then you're talking about
abortion which deprives you of your
right to life and slavery which deprives
you of your right to liberty liberty is
a secondary right you can't have liberty
without
life so of course if those two come into
conflict you've got to go with life
furthermore we know that life is this
precious gift that we have been given
without which we don't have any of the
other rights so putting aside liberal
philosophy for a second just go back to
basics
just remember that life is not a right
it's not just one among many it is the
prerequisite right for all of the other
rights and so of course if you are
deprived of that that is a more grievous
offense than if you are deprived of some
of your autonomy if you are deprived of
a lifetime of autonomy even
but slavery involves suffering yeah well
getting chopped up in the womb involves
suffering too but but
even beyond that
you're telling me that because
one suffers it would be better to die no
one really believes that because we all
suffer and you people who are making
that argument right now
you people out in the twitter verse not
you listeners you're very sensible
people but you libs were making the
argument that if one has to suffer even
immensely like we're talking about with
the case of slavery that it would be
better to die you don't believe that
because you suffer and you don't kill
yourselves which is good you shouldn't
suffering is a fact of life
and suffering can be a bad thing if you
react to suffering in a destructive way
or it can be actually an edifying thing
a sanctifying thing if we react to
suffering with patience and with virtue
it can actually help us to grow
suffering is it's just a it's a fact
okay and it's up to you
to react to that but i don't think that
killing yourself
saying that suffering even immense
suffering justifies
killing yourself or being killed i don't
think that makes a whole lot of sense
of course abortion is much much worse
than slavery and by the way all of you
right side of history people
who look down on our forefathers
and
make more and forget about the
slaveholders for a second just anyone
who came before us who maybe made an
untoward remark or did something that
you disapprove of just you wait just you
wait until you hear what future
generations will say about you which you
will hear because there is a
metaphysical reality and there is heaven
and hell
if if you believe as some of the moderns
do that the whole point of life is just
to get physical pleasure
and a lot of libs believe that
i guess that's the only way that you
could convince yourself that slavery is
worse than abortion
because
life doesn't really matter it's just
this kind of bizarre accident of the
physical universe and we just happen to
think that everything matters and that
we have loves enjoys but it's not it's
just chemicals firing off in our brain
and all we're here to do is get pleasure
so if you die it's no big deal and if
you suffer it's a really big deal and
it's really bad if you believe that
idiotic completely unsubstantiated few
then i guess i guess you could come to
that conclusion but the conclusion
happens to be wrong there's another
controversy i want to address i got i
got in so much trouble
over the weekend on twitter this would
be
a statement i made that there is no
first amendment right to be a kami
okay and so here not only did i irritate
the libs but i irritated some of the
more excitable libertarians
but it turns out i'm right sorry guys
you know i hate to say it but i'm right
there is no a first amendment right to
be a commie there have been many laws in
american history going back to the
earliest administrations going back at
least to the second presidential the
adams administration
that have circumscribed the first
amendment right to free speech to
preclude certain ideas especially if
those ideas are seditious or would lead
to the overthrow of the government
you see this from
federalist administrations you see this
from democratic administrations later on
you see this from the early 20th century
presidents you see this in the 1940s and
50s there's something called the smith
act smith act was used to prosecute
communists and fascists and anarchists
okay
now
some libs will point out well some of
those convictions were overturned yeah
they were that's unfortunate that some
of those convictions were overturned but
the law still remains substantially on
the books
if you in this country still in the u.s
code if you
openly advocate
for the violent overthrow of the united
states government if you write pamphlets
advocating this sort of thing if you
give speeches advocating this sort of
thing you can be prosecuted very often
you're not prosecuted anymore because
we're not as serious a country as we
once were but that is still on the books
folks to pretend that all of those laws
including the smith act were completely
overturned completely deemed
unconstitutional is bs all right and it
comes the reason that
the liberals don't like this is because
the liberals very often have commie
sympathies the reason the libertarians
don't like this is because they have an
unrealistic
anti-historical view of the first
amendment and i like the libertarians so
listen some of my best friends are
libertarians okay but
that view that the first amendment
allows you to say basically whatever you
want
is not true it's philosophically
incoherent and it historically has never
existed okay and i happen to have
written a book about this called
speechless which is selling like
hotcakes by the way it was the number
one national bestseller when it came out
it's still selling great for christmas
so i appreciate it if you have got that
book
for your friends for your family
to
go along a little history of political
correctness the use of language and
politics the first amendment for that
matter really appreciate that there's
another book that you can give to your
liberal friends this christmas to
educate them that would be reasons to
vote for democrats a comprehensive guide
that would be my first book really
appreciate you giving the gift of
knowledge out
speaking of the libs
remaking society
oregon may very well make masks
permanent
not two weeks to slow the spread not
two months of masks not even just
just permanent
the oregon health authority's rules
advisory committee
is reportedly drafting a more quote
permanent set of rules for masking in
the state
despite the fact that the state mass
mandate has already been in place for
months
they're going to make it a little bit
more permanent
this might be this episode today might
be the told you so episode but a lot of
you knew it too it's not like i'm
telling you something that you didn't
know
a lot of us were saying in the comments
and in all access and on the show and
elsewhere we've been saying from almost
the earliest days of the covid stuff
that
there was no end to that it wasn't going
to end in two weeks or two months or
even or even two years
ronald reagan had that line he said
there's nothing nearer to eternal life
on earth than a temporary government
program there's a lot of wisdom in that
statement
that's true
when the government or even when big
corporations or when other powerful
interests take power they very rarely
give it back and the masks are useful to
the powerful
it can be debated how useful they are at
protecting the public health
or slo stopping the spread or slowing
the curve or whatever that you know
beating it back or whatever they talk
about right dr fauci himself seems to
have debated this issue with himself
when he said don't wear the masks they
don't work and then five seconds later
he said do wear the masks they're very
important and you need to wear them all
the time
but what cannot be debated is that as a
political symbol they are very effective
in the beginning of the lockdowns the
libs and the squishes told us that if
you wear the mask it will hasten our
return to normal
some of us out there said the opposite
is true the longer we wear the masks the
longer this is going to go on because
the masks are a visual cue they're a
symbol that things are not normal that
we're living in extraordinary times and
we need to give up extraordinary power
and rights to the people who are
claiming
to to rule us during this emergency
and now they want to make it permanent
it it seems so arbitrary it seems so
capricious but it is a symbol a
political symbol of their ability
to rule
the only way
to take that power back
is politically you know
vote these guys out of office and put in
sane people but also just
push back a little
you know when you're maybe don't be so
quick on the draw
to put the cloth on maybe
use your prudence if you really want to
maybe you really like the masks okay
that's fine
but if as this all seems
this is capricious and arbitrary and
extraordinarily partisan and political
maybe
use your prudence okay that's all i have
is that am i allowed to say that i don't
know
i don't know because the liberal
establishment controls everything
including big tech speaking of political
power
and tech
devin nunes is retiring from congress
he's just announced his retirement from
congress
devin nunes
was
it still is a rising star in the
republican party
he was really good on some of the
government abuse during the trump
administration the deep state abuse
against the trump administration well
now he's leaving congress
i think i think he's leaving even before
his term is over
he's leaving
to run a trump
tech
media enterprise
and people are
the libs are laughing and dancing and
they're so happy and they're even kind
of making fun of him they're saying oh
my gosh you're leaving congress to go do
this crazy thing with trump yes he is
and it makes perfect sense as to why he
is because he didn't have any power in
congress because the power of congress
such as it ever was has been usurped
it's been usurped
in part by the deep state it's been
usurped in part by private industry
because of
deregulation deregulation from the left
in certain cases and deregulation from
the right what what devin nunes is doing
is just what jim demint did when he left
he left the senate because he said he
couldn't do anything in the senate he
went ran heritage now he's running
he's running the cpi another
conservative institute because power
does not lie exactly where we think it
does where i'm a bill up on capitol hill
school house rock told us it was
speaking of shifting political power
there is a horrifying headline coming
out of switzerland
switzerland
has
legalized or is in the process of
legalizing
3d printable suicide pods
an australian doctor philip nichika
it's
kind of fitting that his name is sounds
like nietzsche you know this very
nihilistic brutal ab thinker he has
announced that 3d printed devices that
are being called euthanasia pods
are a coffin-like device that makes
assisted suicide accessible for nearly
everybody and without medical
intervention you don't even know for
your doctor you need a note from your
doctor to kill yourself
will soon be available in switzerland
nietzsche has said that his purpose in
making these devices
is so that everyone can commit suicide
with little medical assistance
suicide pods
this is if you want to
blame the left for this
the culture of death
in a really creepy form
but i think you can blame the right for
this a little bit too
this is capitalism man
this is free enterprise isn't it
this is just a businessman
pursuing his business and giving
consumers choice
he's probably not going to have very
many repeat customers but he's giving
this guy is going to get rich
selling people their death and even if
he doesn't even if he just gives it away
here it's open source you can 3d print
it for free you don't need to pay a
licensing fee
this is just creativity it's creative
destruction it's but definitely
destruction
i bet there are going to be some people
on the right who are okay with this well
it's their choice it's their body their
body their choice there are people on
the right who actually believe that
some people on the right use that
expression ironically to
point out the hypocrisy of liberals who
claim my body my choice
when it comes to abortion but do not
claim my body my choice when it comes to
vaccines
but folks it's it's just a line it's
just a slogan to own the libs we don't
actually believe that we don't i at
least i don't i as a conservative do not
actually believe that you have the right
to do whatever you want with your own
body or to your own body
no we are constrained by the moral order
there is a transcendent moral order and
we are responsible to that we didn't
create our bodies we didn't choose to
come into this world i hope we don't
choose to come out of this world hope we
reject this culture of death from this
lunatic in switzerland or the lunatic in
australia and then the political
lunatics in switzerland
okay we have responsibilities you're not
just allowed to do anything you want
just because you want to we're not just
pure will okay we're also intellect
we're also moral conscience
all right
if this is
something that your political ideology
can look at and not have a problem with
it's probably time to check your
premises
something has probably gone wrong in
your political thinking if you think
this is fine this
represents the literal suicide of the
west the literal suicide of our
civilization that's bad i don't want i
for one don't want that okay and so the
things that are leading our civilization
to commit suicide
whether that is the destruction of our
culture the emptying out of our churches
the breakdown of the bedrock political
institution such as the family and
larger political institutions the
breakdown of loyalty to our own
countries mass migration the decline of
birth rates mass abortion or in this
case literal suicide whatever it is we
got to stop it
because i want to live okay i want to
live
here in this world i want to live
eternally in the spiritual world and i
want our culture and our civilization to
live as well and the libs want it to die
and there are some squishes
who don't really seem to have an opinion
one way or the other they just say well
it's choice well it's whatever you want
well it's the free market well it's
capitalism well no man
there's no neutrality when it comes to
life or death pick a side
speaking of promiscuous sex oh no hold
on there was something i wanted to get
to before before i get to this
it's
promiscuous sex does have a pretty
pretty big role in the
death of the west
but before i get to the biden
administration on this i want to get to
bernie sanders bernie sanders and a lot
of other democrats
are
defending abortion as the central
sacrament
right this is the sacrament of
leftism so bernie says quote we can't go
back to the days when women had to risk
their lives to end an unwanted pregnancy
we must pass legalization that codifies
roe v wade as the law of the land and if
there aren't 60 votes to do it and there
are not
we must reform the filibuster to pass it
with 50.
speaking of neutrality speaking of well
just whatever you want well it's just
free choice well it's the will of the
people no this
kind of thinking this next battle in
abortion rights and pro-life if roe v
wade gets overturned
shows you
the
ultimate weakness of neutral liberalism
or originalism even or textualism
originalism this this
theory this interpretive principle of
reading the constitution that has been
really prominent for several decades now
it may or may not prove effective in
overturning roe v wade i hope it's
effective i'm not sure that it will be
but i hope it is
regardless
we need to make more serious arguments
the arguments that the conservatives
have made for a long time
is
something to this effect
well you know look the roe v wade is
constitutionally completely ridiculous
and it has no basis in the constitution
but that doesn't mean that abortion will
be outlawed or necessarily even should
be outlawed new york is going to have
abortion tennessee is not going to have
abortion and that's federalism and
that's just you know we're talking about
the text for the constitution and then
the people can make their own decision
okay i get why that argument is
instrumental instrumentally useful and
true and as far as it is true
but
it's not good enough
i don't
i hope that roe v wage is overturned i
hope there's no pretend federal right to
an abortion
but i don't i don't want there to be
abortion in new york either i don't want
there to be abortion in connecticut
either and i don't give a damn if the
new yorkers and the californians want it
it's wrong
we the people have the right to say that
it's wrong
and states rights only goes so far the
question of states writes to do
what
we're going to leave it there we're not
going to talk about any more promiscuous
sex today even though there's a juicy
story coming out of the white house
that's going to be the cliffhanger i'll
see you tomorrow i'm michael moses the
michael knowles show
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021. on
the matte wall show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you your family our country not
just politics but culture faith current
events all the fundamentals if they
matter to you come check out the show